Hi and welcome to The Winning Factor. I'm Alan Aitken and on this show each week
大家好，歡迎收聽《致勝要素》節目，我是艾倫·艾特肯，本週節目中……
we take a look at some upcoming races in Hong Kong, try to identify an angle to
我們將檢視香港即將舉行的賽事，嘗試找出切入角度。
the race that might lead us to finding the winner. Well it's Saturday racing
這場可能揭曉勝者的賽事，將於星期六登場。
this weekend in Hong Kong and the first race I'm going to take a look at is race
本週末於香港，我首先將關注嘅係第一場賽事。
10 where our winning factor is the map. So this is class 3 1600 meters and
第十場，我們嘅致勝關鍵係地圖。呢場係三級賽，途程一千六百米，而家……
And Blazing Wukong and Amazing Partners are coming off last start wins.
「烈焰悟空」同「驚奇拍檔」均於上仗取勝。
Endured has been racing well in similar events without much luck.
Endured 在類似賽事中表現不俗，惟始終未能取勝。
Smart Avenue should improve with a better draw.
「智道」應可憑較佳賽程表現提升。
And Family Jewel and Hymnbook both look to have chances as well.
「Family Jewel」同「Hymnbook」亦似乎都有機會勝出。
So not a one horse race by any means.
所以這絕對不是一邊倒的賽事。
Quite a few chances.
機會相當多。
But I'm looking most closely at a couple of horses I think will cope with what looks quite a tricky event in terms of the map.
不過我主要關注幾匹馬，我認為牠們能應付這場地圖看來相當棘手的賽事。
And that's Blazing Wukong and Amazing Partners.
這就是《火熱悟空》同《精彩夥伴》。
Now, Amazing Partners, first of all, well, he's lightly raced.
現在，Amazing Partners，首先，牠出賽次數較少。
He's only had six starts for three wins.
他僅出賽六場，取得三勝。
And this was his latest when he tackled 1,600 metres for the first time.
這正是他首次挑戰一千六百公尺時的最後一役。
This is race 601. He's in gate four pink colours.
這是第 601 場賽事，他位於四號閘，身穿粉紅色賽衣。
And Amazing Partners jumps well. He isn't a quick horse naturally.
「驚奇夥伴」跳躍出色，但天生並非速度型賽駒。
But Vincent Ho is able to get him into a position near the lead
但何兆基能將他帶至接近領先的位置。
through what is a slow first sectional
首節比賽節奏緩慢。
before the pace does pick up a little through the middle stages,
在中段階段速度稍為加快之前，
but still is only steady.
但始終僅屬平穩。
A number of Saturday's rivals are here too.
本週六的多支對手球隊亦已蒞臨。
In Jude, inside amazing partners in red and grey,
在朱德，驚艷的紅灰搭檔。
Mr Dapper, the leader, and Himbuk in green near the tail.
達珀先生為領袖，身著綠色服裝的欣布克則位於尾部附近。
Now, the field is bunched here with no serious pace
現時賽場上馬羣聚集，缺乏嚴謹的步速。
and becomes just a dash down the straight,
並成為直線上一個小小的破折號，
with in Jude on the inside having no luck.
猶大在內部毫無進展。
But amazing partners, well, he's able to be challenging
但令人讚嘆嘅合作夥伴，的確能帶來挑戰。
at the right time with enough turn of foot
在恰當時機並具備足夠的靈活性。
to reel in the leaders and he grinds out the win.
他成功吸引領袖加入，並穩紮穩打贏得勝利。
Now, despite his good winning record, three from six amazing partners,
現時，儘管他擁有優異的勝出紀錄，並與三位表現出色的搭檔合作；
I don't really think we've seen the best of him yet
我並不認為我們已經見識到他最出色的一面。
because he's been in several of these kinds of races
因為他已參加過多次同類賽事。
where it's just a grinding sort of finish,
那是一種類似研磨的質感表面。
difficult to get separation on the field.
難以在場上取得分離效果。
So he's done well to put that record together
因此他成功籌組了該紀錄片。
and that could be a key thing in Saturday's race.
這或許是星期六賽事的一個關鍵因素。
Now, Blazing Wukong, on the other hand,
然而，另一方面，《烈焰悟空》則……
He's a little bit more well explored with 11 starts so far for three wins.
他至今已出賽十一場，取得三場勝利，表現相對較為受矚目。
And here's his latest offering.
以下是他最新推出之作。
This is race 643, gate 13 in black colours.
此為第 643 場賽事，13 號閘道，馬匹著黑色衣飾。
And Blazing Wukong jumps okay, but jockey Andrea Azzini doesn't even think of looking for a more forward position going back to the rear.
「烈焰悟空」跳躍表現尚可，但騎師安德里亞·阿齊尼甚至未考慮在折返時採取更前位的策騎位置。
Now, that prevents him covering extra ground early.
這使他在初期無法覆蓋更多距離。
But we can see on the heat map it's also a disadvantage with the slow early speed here.
但從熱力圖可見，這裡早段速度偏慢亦構成劣勢。
The pace is a little better mid-race but never really gets above steady.
比賽中段步伐稍為加快，但始終未能超越平穩節奏。
Blazing Wukong then sprints well around the field, deceptively fast around the field in
烈火悟空隨即飛快繞場奔馳，其速度令人難以察覺地迅捷。
fact as they turn into the stretch and he's the one with the acceleration to go and pick
事實係佢哋進入最後直路時，佢擁有加速力去爭奪領先位置。
up the leaders and put them away.
請將領導人帶走並安置。
Just like Amazing Partners, not the most impressive win to the eye but what they have in common
同「卓越夥伴」一樣，雖然這場勝利未必最奪目，但兩者實有共通之處。
is that each of them had to produce acceleration at the right time, the right place to go and
是他們每個人都必須在恰當的時間和地點產生加速度以達成目標。
win the race and as I said I think that's going to be important in the context of Saturday's race.
贏得這場比賽，正如我所説，我認為這對週六的賽事至關重要。
Now the leaders Mr Dapper and with all my faith have the outside gates so that is the hope of the
現時領袖達柏先生與我全心的信念已掌握外圍門户，此乃希望所在。
side as far as getting a better speed but it's quite possible they could get across quickly and
就提升速度而言固然有利，但他們完全有可能迅速橫渡過去。
then steady the brakes and we might have a similar style of race to what we've been seeing.
若制動系統穩定，我們或許會見到與以往相似的賽道風格。
There still looks a little speed in it, inside or out, and that's not going to help the likes
無論內在外表，它似乎仍帶有一絲速度感，而這對我們這類人來説並無助益。
of Family Jewel, Endured and others who have wider draws, while Hymnbook and Smart Avenue
「Family Jewel」、「Endured」及其他吸引力較大的馬匹，以及「Hymnbook」和「Smart Avenue」。
have never really shown as much tactical speed yet, regardless of their draw.
無論賽果如何，他們尚未展現出如此迅捷的戰術速度。
Now Blazing Wukong went all the way back last time.
如今，《烈焰悟空》上次已一路返回。
We have seen him ridden like that quite a bit, but he has also had a lot of wider draws.
我們已多次見他處於此類騎乘狀況，但他亦曾獲得較寬闊的起跑位置。
This time he's got a better draw, so he might even be closer from barrier five.
今次他抽得較佳檔位，甚至可能從五號欄出發時更具優勢。
But we do know that Amazing Partners has the tactical speed to be where he needs to be
但我們確知「Amazing Partners」具備所需戰術速度，能及時到位。
again.
再次。
So the tip from me in race 10, Amazing Partners, his winning factor, the map.
第十場賽事我的建議：Amazing Partners，其勝出關鍵在於賽道。
It does look a very tricky map, but it could be a stop start kind of race.
呢張地圖睇落好複雜，但賽事實情可能係走走停停嘅類型。
But what we've seen from Amazing Partners, even in those kinds of races, is that he's
但從「Amazing Partners」的表現來看，即使是在這類賽事中，他亦展現出……
able to put himself in the right place.
能夠置身於恰當的位置。
able to accelerate at the right time and that might be the winning recipe for this event.
能夠在恰當時機加速，或許就是本賽事致勝的關鍵。
The other race I want to take a look at on Sunday is the final event, race 11 and our
另一場我星期日想關注嘅賽事係第 11 場，亦即係最後一場比賽，而我們...
winning factor here, the draw.
此處致勝關鍵在於抽籤結果。
So this is class two, an excellent class two in fact, over 1200 metres and despite the
所以這是第二場賽事，實際上是一場優異的兩歲馬賽事，途程超過一千二百米，儘管……
talent in the race, I think we can narrow this down to three really strong chances.
參賽人才眾多，我認為可將範圍縮窄至三個極具勝算的候選人。
a patch of stars who continues to race well,
一匹表現持續出色的賽駒。
and two horses we expect to see figuring in some serious races in the future,
另外兩匹馬，我們預期牠們日後會參加一些重要賽事。
Jamie Richards' trained Bulb General and the unbeaten three-year-old Hot Delight.
由佔美·理查茲策騎嘅訓練有素嘅「燈泡總司令」，同埋保持不敗紀錄嘅三歲馬「熱切喜悦」。
And I'm most interested in this race in those two lightly raced horses.
我對這場賽事最感興趣的，是這兩匹出賽次數較少的馬匹。
As I said, Hot Delight, unbeaten, three from three,
正如我剛才所説，熱力歡喜保持不敗，三戰全勝。
and Bulb General, a year older, and he's three wins from five starts.
布爾布將軍年長一歲，五場賽事已取得三勝。
Now, firstly, Hot Delight, and his trainer, Francis Loy,
現在首先介紹的是「熱力歡欣」及其練馬師劉國威，
has made comparisons at the same stage with a horse that you might be familiar with that he
在同一階段與一匹你可能熟悉嘅馬進行比較，而他
used to train, Golden 60. That's a big call. Certainly there's a lot of water to flow under
曾用於訓練「黃金六十」。此舉影響深遠，顯然尚需時日方能見效。
the bridge for that one, but he can't be faulted in what he's done so far. This is race 540. He's
那座橋是為他而設，但就他所做的一切而言，無人可指責。這是第 540 場賽事，他……
in gate seven in yellow and red colours and Hot Delight jumps well for Vincent Ho and is quickly
七號馬「黃紅」及「熱帶歡欣」由何卓輝策騎，表現出色且迅速。
up on the speed in what you can see is a slow first 400 metre section with Ho on the odds
速度方面，可見首四百米步伐緩慢，霍恩是熱門馬匹。
on favourite here taking bad luck out of the equation.
在此精選項目中，我們已排除運氣不佳的因素。
Now the pace does lift a little as the race progresses then becomes a strong sprint home
隨著賽事推進，步速稍為加快，隨後進入強勁的衝刺階段。
down the stretch.
進入最後階段。
The leader fights on well but ultimately Hot Delight is too good and comes clear to win
領放馬表現出色，但最終「熱歡」實力更勝一籌，成功脱穎而出奪冠。
with some conviction.
帶著一些信念。
Now perhaps to the eye not deserving the kind of boom that we're talking about on this horse
現時這匹馬或許在旁人眼中，未必值得我們所討論的如此蓬勃發展。
But the way the race was run there meant that to win it the way he did,
但是當時比賽進行方式意味著要像他那樣奪冠，
Hot Delight had to break 44 seconds for his last 800 metres.
「熱力」最後八百米必須跑入四十四秒。
And that's the kind of sustained speed that is going to make this young horse
而這種持續的步速將令這匹年輕賽馬……
a star of the future as he develops and grows stronger.
他日漸茁壯，必成未來之星。
As to Bulb General, well, as I mentioned, he's a year older.
至於布爾·傑納爾，正如我剛才提及，他年長一歲。
And really, he was this time last year where Hot Delight is now.
事實上，他去年此時正處於與「熱切喜悦」目前相同的位置。
He was an up-and-comer with a great turn of foot as a three-year-old.
他三歲時已展現出極佳的跑動能力，被視為前途無量的新星。
He took that into his early starts as a four-year-old,
他將這因素帶入其四歲初出賽的表現中，
but then his career was interrupted by injury.
但隨後他的職業生涯因傷而中斷。
He's only had the one run back in March,
他自三月以來只跑過一次。
and let's have a look at how he handled that.
讓我們看看他是如何處理此事的。
This is race 562, gate seven here in orange and white colours.
此為第五六二號賽事，七號閘位，採用橙白配色。
Bulb General jumps well for Zach Burton,
布爾布·傑納爾為扎克·伯頓作出出色跳躍。
but this race is a contrast with the one that we just saw,
但這場賽事與我們剛才所見形成鮮明對比，
as the early speed here is pretty good.
由於此處初段步速相當理想。
Zach lets Bulb General find his feet as is usual and he ends up towards the rear with
查克讓布爾將軍像往常一樣穩住陣腳，結果他卻落到了後方。
another of Saturday's rivals Patch of Stars in yellow, white and blue a few lengths ahead
星期六的另一位勁敵「Patch of Stars」身披黃白藍三色戰袍，已領先數個馬位。
of him on the rail.
他站在鐵軌上。
Now the pace increases again mid-race so it's really run to suit horses off the pace and
現時賽事中段步速再次加快，因此極適合那些習慣跟隨慢步速的賽駒發揮。
when they straighten up Patch of Stars comes to pounce, he comes up short behind Young
當他們站直時，「星羣」撲向對方，卻在揚恩身後未能及身。
Champion with Bulb General working home steadily into third.
「冠軍」馬在布爾將軍策騎下穩步推進至第三。
Now Bob General will meet the first two that beat him home there on Saturday, but they
現在鮑勃將軍將與上週六率先衝線的前兩名賽駒會面，但他們……
were hard race fit horses and he was coming off quite a lengthy break.
牠是適合硬地賽事的馬匹，且剛結束了一段較長的休養期。
So I do think he's going to tighten up and be a better version of himself on Saturday.
所以我相信他星期六會收緊狀態，展現出更出色的自己。
But I think when we go to the draw, that's where things are really getting interesting
但我想當我們進入抽籤階段時，事情才會真正變得精彩。
in this race.
在這次賽事中。
There's good speed out wide here from Victor the winner, Crimson Flash and Ladies Choice.
維克多勝出，紅閃電與淑女選擇在兩翼展現出色速度。
So the tempo looks sound enough.
所以節奏看來相當合適。
Bob General is drawn lower this time, while he's still not going to be on the front end
鮑勃·傑尼拉爾今次排位較低，他仍無法處於領放位置。
of the race.
關於該賽事。
His jockey this time, Joe Marrera, should be able to use that draw to get a nice trip
他今次嘅騎師喬·馬雷拉應可善用呢個檔位取得理想跑線。
through the race.
透過賽事。
Harry Bentley takes over on Hot Delight with the light weight, but his map looks filled
哈利·本特利接手「熱力」號，雖然載重輕盈，但他嘅航圖卻顯示滿載。
with a lot of decisions to make, and tough ones they are.
面臨眾多決策，而且都是艱難的抉擇。
We saw Hot Delight up on the speed, his last two starts in slow tempos, but with a better
我們看到「熱誠」在速度上表現出色，雖然牠最近兩場賽事節奏較慢，但整體表現更佳。
pace and a wide draw here he would have trouble getting to a similar spot without covering ground
以當前速度及寬闊的跑位，若無覆蓋更多地面，他將難以抵達相似位置。
and working and might even have to drag all the way back in the field so that he doesn't have a
並持續工作，甚至可能需要將他拖回田間深處，以免他……
difficult run so the tip from me in race 11 bulb general his winning factor the draw now had they
十一場賽事賽道艱難，我的建議是布爾·傑納爾，他勝出的關鍵因素在於今日檔位。
drawn the other way around i'm sure that i would have been tipping hot delight but his job looks
反過來説，我敢肯定我會感到極度興奮，但他的工作看來……
full of difficulties. He's good enough to overcome them. I certainly don't want to
充滿困難，但他足以克服它們，我絕不希望如此。
say it's lights out for his chances but it brings him back to the older horse
雖説他勝算已微，但此舉卻令他重回老將之列。
who has drawn better this time, Bulb General, and should be fitter than he was
是次由布爾將軍抽得較佳位置，狀態應比上次更佳。
for that first up run. Well that's it from the Winning Factor this week. Good
而家係本週《贏家因素》嘅最後一節，多謝各位收聽。
luck on Saturday. We'll see you next time.
星期六祝你好運，下次再見。